en el último vídeo hicimos algunos
ejercicios de multiplicación de rejillas
y viste que era sencillo esto viste que
primero multiplicadas y despues sumadas
pero aquí voy a intentar
vamos a intentar entender por qué
funciona esto porque para casi parece
magia cierto entonces voy a volver a
hacer estos dos ejemplos y voy a
explicar por qué funciona el método de
rejillas entonces voy a poner aquí el 27
x el 48 los colocó de esta manera y voy
a poner al 2 le pongo su columna también
al 7 le pongo su columna al 4 le pongo
su fila y también al 8 le pongo su fila
y aquí lo primordial lo principal aquí
son las diagonales
estas diagonales ahora puedes pensarlo
de esta manera cada una de estas
diagonales tiene un lugar una posición
entonces por ejemplo esta primer
diagonal corresponde a las unidades
ahora vamos con la siguiente diagonal la
que está sobre esta esta diagonal
corresponde a las decenas pongo aquí
decenas y esta diagonal que voy a poner
en este color esta diagonal corresponde
a las centenas esto centenas y puedes
adivinar la siguiente diagonal
esta última corresponde a los millares
entonces cada vez que multiplicas un
dígito por otro dígito simplemente
asegúrate de ponerlo en el lugar
correcto
ya verás a qué me refiero aquí
multiplicamos 7 por 8 y 7 por 8 es igual
a 28 ajá aquí está 7 por 8 es igual a 28
escribimos el 28 de esta manera pero qué
fue lo que fue lo que pasó aquí este 7
en 27 no es un 7 normal aunque parezca
ahora bien este 4 parece normal pero no
es un 4 normal es el 4 en 48 y 48 lo
puedes ver como 40
a las 8 entonces ese 4 no es un 4 es 40
puedes ver que no estábamos
multiplicando 7 por 4 sino 7 por 47 por
40 no es igual a 28 sino 287 por 40 es
igual a 280 donde a 280 lo podemos ver
como dos centenas dos centenas más ocho
decenas y eso es exactamente lo mismo
que escribimos aquí nota que está
diagonal está diagonal corresponde a las
decenas es la diagonal de las decenas
cuando yo multiplique siete por cuarenta
pusimos el ocho aquí en la diagonal de
las decenas y siete por cuarenta es
igual a dos centenas más ocho decenas
puse el dos en las centenas y el ocho en
las decenas aquí escribimos 280 cierto
entonces sigamos con esto vamos con la
siguiente multiplicación cuando
multiplicados por cuatro tal vez tú
digas
8 pero observa por qué porque ese 2 en
27 no es un 2 es un 20 y este es un 40
así que estamos multiplicando 20 por 40
lo cual es igual a 800 cierto esto es
igual a 800 y ahora que hicimos aquí yo
multiplique 2 por 4 igual a 8 pusimos el
0 ahí el 8 acá el 8 lo pongo en el lugar
de las centenas en la diagonal de las
centenas y aunque parezca que
multiplique 2 por 4 igual a 8 lo que
hicimos fue realmente 20 por 40 eso es
igual a 800 entonces es la diagonal de
las centenas simplemente recuerda eso es
importante y bueno sigamos con la
siguiente multiplicación 7 por 8 ok el 7
en 27 es un 7 normal ajá y el 8 en 48
también es un 8 normal está en las
unidades y no hay nada especial ahora 7
por 8 es igual a 56 pongo el 6 en las
unidades
y el 5 en las escenas porque 56 es 50 6
ahora vamos con con 2 por 8 o que cuando
multiplicamos 2 por 8 eso es igual a 16
pero el 2 está en 27 es un 20 no es un 2
entonces lo que estamos haciendo en
realidad es multiplicar 20 por 8 lo cual
es igual a 160 pongo el 6 en las decenas
y el 1 en las centenas y ya así de
sencillo ahora con la multiplicación por
el método de rejillas lo que hicimos fue
colocada cada número en en su en su
respectivo lugar en un lugar correcto el
6 en las unidades el 6 5 y 8 en las
decenas el 18 y 2 en las centenas y nada
en los millares ahora ya tenemos a cada
dígito en su lugar y ya multiplicamos ya
sacamos todo eso ahora vamos a sumar así
que en marcha sumemos esto el 6 en las
unidades se queda igual es un 6
simplemente y en las decenas 8 5
es igual a 19 pero nota que estamos
estamos en las escenas entonces es 19
decenas es decir 9 decenas y una centena
ajá llevamos 1 en las centenas y ahora
vamos a sumar las centenas tenemos 100
más 200 más 800 y más 100 otra vez eso
es igual a mil 200 y eso 1200 es igual a
1000 más 200 pongo un 2 aquí en las en
las centenas y llevamos un millar lo
pongo acá arriba entonces un millar va
en este lugar aquí voy a poner un 1 y ya
entonces pongo uno ahí y es el mismo
razonamiento para este ejemplo así que
pongamos pongamos etiqueta a cada
diagonal en este ejemplo esta diagonal
corresponde a las unidades cuando
multiplicamos 9 por 7 es igual a 63
puedes ver que tenemos seis decenas y
tres unidades esta diagonal corresponde
las decenas ahora cuándo multiplicamos 9
por 80 porque recuerda que 787 es igual
a 700 más 87 entonces 9 por 8 es igual a
9 por 80 lo cual es igual a 720 ajá así
que está diagonal está diagonal es la
que corresponde a las centenas y ahora
ahora está diagonal corresponde a los
millares corresponde a los millares ésta
corresponde a las decenas de millar ésta
corresponde a las centenas de millar y
esta última diagonal a los millones
primero hicimos la multiplicación cada
dígito fue colocado en en su lugar
correcto y eso es lo que representa cada
uno de estos números por ejemplo esta
entrada parece que multiplicamos 4 por 8
igual a 32 pero
lo que en realidad hicimos fue
multiplicar 400 por 80 y 400 por 80 eso
es igual a 32 y tres ceros 32.000 ajá
así que genial porque observa esto este
2 está en la diagonal de las de los
millares ajá así que es 2000 y el 3 el
13 está en las escenas de millar
entonces aquí tenemos tres decenas de
millar más dos millares
treinta y dos mil así que la
multiplicación por el método de rejillas
tal vez te parezca algo bizarro o mágico
no lo sé pero la clave simplemente está
en colocar a cada número en su
respectivo lugar ya sea en las unidades
decenas centenas lo que sea y este
método me gusta porque te permite poner
a tu cerebro en modo multiplicación y
después cambiarlo a modo suma y eso es
bastante cómodo nos vemos pronto